allez on regarde regarde je suis
vraiment un grand fan de
je suis un grand fan de votre émission
déjà je vais vous le dire c'est toujours
dur aux gars de contrer par la décote ça
faisait plaisir comme regarder un ouais
mais tu sais je suis fan jour continue
avec les les agriculteurs dans les
tracteurs et que fait de points que ça
l'amour de vie mais nous mais ça c'est
très cocasse mais nous vous trompez quoi
mais parce que j'ai deux émissions y en
a une au chu coquine et on a une je suis
vilaine vous parlez de celle avec les
gros tracteurs oui ciboure les chambres
qui sont en jachère depuis longtemps
celle ci a ajouté le texte
tu as beaucoup improvisé là dessus je
vous dis la vérité soir deal avec des
sketches que j'ai le plus travaillé de
tous les skateurs effet jusqu'ici
pourquoi tu sentais que c'était hyper
important de son deck salle est un
taureau en fait quand arrive c'était la
première fois que j'allais travailler
avec gad elmaleh ouais on sait tous ce
qui égalait la manette ils reçoivent
olemps mois que le frère et j'avais une
pression mais c'était incroyable j'avais
fait le marrakech du rire j'ai
l'impression mais c'était pas ouf
hélas d'être avec gad elmaleh savais que
j'avais un duo avec lui que j'allais
faire un sketch
j'ai bossé comme en fait j'ai regardé je
crois 2h02 sur youtube de car il ya un
truc et je le dis parce que gad ses
rythmes aussi j'ai fait j'avais fait
l'émission et c'est un mec voilà mine de
rien il te met il te ment confiance de
ouf et il ay voilà ils portent les mecs
c'est à dire que tu as lu twilight à
porter il y avait pas mal d'impro après
est peu apprécié un génie de l'impro
donc forcément pas franchement ça ça
reste un très très gros montant
évidemment leur passé puisque karine va
recevoir gad elmaleh et qu'elle a
prévenu évidemment de repasser à 8
colère si on a les infos de la source
même si froid elle heureusement ça vaut
le coup d'avoir un cdi